[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
[Musik]
mein name ist philipp pickler ich
schreibe bücher und ich spreche auch
über bücher zum beispiel im sf
literaturclub unter messeformat steiner
und tingler und ich bin unterwegs in die
kunsthalle zürich um die gilbert and
george retrospektive anzugucken mit
daniel baumann dem direktor ich freue
mich sehr auf diesen termin nicht nur
weil ich mich für die bilder
interessiere sondern auch für das was
eigentlich kunst ausmacht
mein name ist daniel baumann direktor
der kunsthalle zürich und hatte durch
sein fraktionskollege wo mir gemeinsam
mit luna west organisiert nötige guten
tag wenn man hier mit dem vierten
treffer in acht orten machen
hallo es freut mich sehr bei ihnen zu
sagen ich habe mich toll sei ja bitte
gern jetzt kann ich auch die
sonnenbrille
[Musik]
ja
es ist noch dunkel da drin herr baumann
sie müssen auch noch das licht
einschalten sondern verlauf ich mich im
dunkel mache ich gleich es gibt mir auch
das gefühl ich wäre der erste
dabei bin ich der einzige ein wichtiger
unterschied herr baumann findet die
lichtschalter nicht aber ich bin zum
glück gewöhnt über so pausen hinweg zu
reden was ich auch jetzt sehr gut tun
kann indem ich einfach dass ausspreche
ungefiltert was mir durch den kopf geht
und in dem ich das tue ist es auch schon
hell geworden so herzlich willkommen
vielen dank das kleine meine plastik
jacke ausziehen wenn ich darf denn mir
wird jetzt schon warm
bisher gehören gut ich habe auch das
gefühl durch diesen hall effekt ich
würde die ganze zeit schreiend spreche
ich zu laut nein völlig okay gut also
was machen wir machen wir einen
systematischen rundgang darf ich am
anfang eine frage stellen ja sie dürfen
aber es machen will müsste eben mit
dieser distanz ein bisschen nach jährige
wir müssen immer wieder erst es wäre
praktisch und tod eine schöne lücke
zwischen uns
das ist interessant dass sie das sagen
wer jetzt fällt mir auf dass auch auf
den bildern eigentlich immer eine
gewisse distanz zwischen gilbert &
george besteht die sie berühren einander
da doch richter sind sie zusammen drauf
ja
ich es unten ist schwarz gelben und dann
haben sie gedreht
richtig und wir befinden uns ja in einer
retrospektive nicht wahr
genau denn ich habe mich gefragt ist es
jetzt quasi also das thema der schau
sind einfach fünf jahrzehnte gilbert &
george was für eine ziemlich lange zeit
eine ziemlich lange zeit für ein paar
nicht in der tat ja und und warum macht
man eigentlich eine retrospektive
ich glaube schon um noch mal zu schauen
ob das taugt was wirklich gut ist und
was es heute noch zu sagen hat nicht die
sachen sind manchmal gebe etwas aus er
verliert sein werk wird uninteressant
langweilig dorf und plötzlich 30 jahre
später wird es wieder interessant und
das heißt die bilder sind auch quasi
chronologisch gehängt die inhaltlichen
aspekten gehängt nein also dass das
wirklich einziger dass alle
ausstellungen wird von gilbert & george
gemacht also ich hab nix gemacht haben
so wie ich ob ich es hat nichts gemacht
niemand macht was kein kurator nichts
das sind die zwei künstler die machen
was schicken dass wir uns auf das ist
jede hängung und die haben dann sich
entschieden zu mischen nicht so
langweilig chronologisch von hier bis da
aber a bis z sondern das sind
verschiedene zeit nicht 94 13 2006 und
soweit ist alles gemischt und erkennen
sie jetzt gesichtspunkte der auswahl
also wird ihn so deutlich warum gilbert
im job diese motive ausgewählt haben
sehen sie eine art von gedanklicher
linie oder oder spielt es gar keine
rolle die ich schon viel zu weit
ich habe mir nie so überlegt weil ich
eigentlich und dann kommt natürlich
mitten in die sache rein einfach mal zu
es genossen haben
diese bild welt zu sehen dass durch
etwas was man fast nicht sagen dass man
einfach mal genießt
doch etwas finde ich einen sehr
wichtigen aspekt ich bin auch froh dass
ich solche sachen sagen aber sie haben
recht wenn für meine begriffe wenn sie
sagen das ist ein bisschen eine schon
fast an richtig ist so was zu sagen
von professioneller worte aus dem sommer
signalisiert
ja davon bin ich dann mal schauen
[Musik]
das ist nur ein raum von 3 und dann gibt
es noch an den bäumen gibt es eben noch
älter arbeiten und wirklich dieses
interessant als eigentlich ein tagebuch
ich mag kann dadurch 40 jahre wie ein
tagebuch durch nicht da hat es da ist
natürlich so schwulenszene park dass ich
dann gleich auch noch hinterfragen jacke
oder automatisch als schule etikettiert
wieso ist dass die schulen weil
natürlich okay weil es bei abgebildet
ist wenn man die geschichte dahinter
kennt okay aber sollte man kunst nicht
auch konsumieren können ohne dass man
die geschichte war aber beides nicht das
eine oder das andere mann war auf beides
machen es heißt ja nicht wenn man aus
weiß und 20 etwas verbieten nein
durchaus ich sehe wir haben eine
interessante diskussion vor uns aber ich
habe eigentlich unterbrochen sie wollten
ich wollte einfach noch mal sagen mich
diese tagebuch geschichte 94 und 2006
das sind die bombenattentate in london
da geht es natürlich um tod zeitung
medien
da drüben an batman 2013 diskutiert wo
sie wohnen das sich verändert und dann
plötzlich frauen in die jobs auftauchen
das thematisieren sie dann dieses
komische gefäß diese bombe aber es ist
ja dieses lachgas was auch dort
konsumiert mit dem straßen von den kids
unterweisung sofort ist eigentlich auch
ein tagebuch ein panorama der letzten
vierzig fünfzig jahre und man macht sich
natürlich richtige fragen provokative
fragen gar nicht hier job da was ich
gerade gesagt habe schulen park nein ja
wie soll man damit umgehen was gehts
sein
ich finde das interessante an der
provokation ist ja dass das provokation
immer noch möglich ist das ist der erste
punkt man sollte ja eigentlich denkt man
hat so vieles gesehen dass provokation
nicht mehr so leicht dass in der kunst
wie früher
aber das stimmt überhaupt nicht
provokation hat sich einfach verlagert
auf andere themen zum beispiel eben auf
den ideen
das ist dass es provokant das dahingegen
baumhaus ist überhaupt nicht mehr
provokant war damals genau schon deshalb
quasi den den zeitlichen charakter auf
oder auch die verschiebung in der
wahrnehmung als provokativ genau und
wenn man jetzt ich finde das eben ganz
abzusagen wenn man sagt okay die der
provokative effekt von den boards ist
weg was bleibt dann von dem bild hat das
bild noch einen anderen wert außer der
provokation die es früher mal
dargestellt hat da kann man jetzt
argumentieren nicht ich glaube ein web
data bleibt ist der humor ich diese
komischen gesichtet die damen gegen
chance hat etwas ab so dass ich mich
zwei potter es nicht des kicker gilbert
& george dahinter potreck uns über die
zwei gäste jetzt hat man da einmal die 2
die lichter nicht ja die alten gesichter
die welt das gesicht von hinten unten
und dann kann man natürlich damit auch
lustig nicht was ist ein porträt also
dann kommt für mich schon noch eine
andere geschichte da kann ich sagen auch
noch ich haben wir sehen also was
überlegen ist nur ein gesicht und wurde
zweite auch
[Musik]
man könnte man sich auch mal so richtig
ist das eine schöne komposition
vielleicht sogar ja das sind
interessante fragen genau das bringt uns
quasi richtung zu kriterien die die man
objektive kriterien nennen kann also wie
ist eigentlich die komposition eines bin
was macht eigentlich den künstlerischen
gehalt aus liegt es auch in der art und
weise wie etwas ausgeführt ist wie etwas
arrangiert ist die bilder sind ja für
mich jetzt als weihnachten betrachter in
der art und weise wie sie gemacht sind
alle relativ ähnlich sie sind alle sehr
sehr sehr deutlich sehr plakativ im
wahrsten sinne des wortes dann haben sie
alle dieses raster von dem ich irgendwo
gelesen habe es kann auch ein bisschen
an kirchenfenster an die bemalung von
kirchenfenstern erinnern
ja und sie sind alle auch in ihrer in
ihrer farbwahl recht limitiert sind alle
ziemlich deutlich und ich habe mich ja
auch ein bisschen vorbereitet damit ich
ihn also doch
und ich habe gelesen dass deutlichkeit
verstellbarkeit lesbarkeit ein wichtiger
anspruches von gilbert & george die mir
sagen unsere kunst ist nicht kryptisch
unserer grenzt ist sofort verständlich
und damit sagen sie also die künstler
auch demokratisch sie wollen eben dass
er großes kompliment ist nicht wenn wir
zwei haben auch tolle bild und sein
großes kompliment st
das ist ein großes jemand in der straße
der innen komplett da kann man sicher
sagen dass das deren ihr großes
kompliment ist wir müssen natürlich auch
jede verlautbarung die sie von sich
geben genauso kinder durch den filter
ziehen wie wir hier diese bilder durch
im feld der kritischen felder ziehen
müssen ich bin noch 1 punkt weiter
zurück in der debatte nämlich ist es
eigentlich gut oder schlecht wenn bilder
einfach zu lesen sind ist derweil
einfach heißt ja auch eindeutig diese
bilder lassen ja eigentlich auch nur
einen sehr geringen spielraum von
lesarten zu also die sind nicht sehr
ambivalent und das heißt dass der
betrachter in die position gebracht wird
ich sie entweder ich sehe das was
intendiert ist es relativ einfach ist
relativ deutlich ist oder ich kann halt
gar nichts sehen und nichts damit
anfangen aber es gibt wie keine zwischen
bereiche also ich finde das noch mal
anders aus rückt auch relativ flach
vielleicht in jeder hinsicht also etwas
plakatives will aber auch so sein
ja genau das ist dann wieder diese frage
will aber auch so sein wo ich dann immer
sage ja das ist so wie wenn wie im
literaturclub ein buch diskutieren und
dann wird gesagt ja das soll ist aber
auch so als collage angelegt und dann
frage ich mich immer so leisten wir hier
die arbeit des künstlers oder das auto
zu dem wir sagen ja genau das hat zwar
gewiss in führung aber das ist so
angelegt dass will auch so sein
natürlich wollen die bilder so sagen wie
sie sind aber reicht das
[Musik]
da geht es darum eigentlich sehr kräuter
zu befreien und zwei das ganz wichtiges
thema gegen die religion zu kämpfen
in ganz brasilien sie religion ab und
sind empört darüber dass heute menschen
immer noch wegen ihrer sexualität im
gefängnis landen
wenn man dann mit dem unter dem
gesichtspunkt durchgeht erkennt man
plötzlich auch eine plakativität jedem
da ist weil es denen um etwas geht die
wollen eine message rüberbringen dann
kann man auch diskutieren ist das blog
hat die für eine gute art und weise
message über zu bringen es ist eine
möglichkeit würde ich mal sagen
dann stellte ich mir die frage gut wir
stehen jetzt in einer retrospektive fünf
dekaden was ist eigentlich an
künstlerischer entwicklung passiert also
gibt es irgendwelche linien wo sich was
getan hat seit 1970 oder es ist einfach
immer nur wieder das gleiche wenn wir
wenn der marken analogie bleiben produkt
was in verschiedenen packages serviert
wird und es werde daran schlecht daran
wäre schlecht das ist
ich bin ein altmodischer mensch ich bin
vielleicht altmodisch halten
ich erwarte von einem künstler oder von
einem künstler duo was so lange tätig
ist eine art von entwicklung und zwar
deshalb weil ich finde man gelegentlich
sehen kann dass die leute sonst so an
die grenze zu einer tragischen
selbstparodie kommen aber ist diese
diese vorstellung von entwicklung ist
das nicht auch etwas was man auch sagen
könnte okay das ist der klassische
westliches denkschema zwar erwartet von
der hohen kunst aber man kann man eben
diesen unterschied noch macht dass es
diese entwicklung gibt ja aber das ist
doch hier hohe kunst oder nur gesagt
dass ich bin davon ausgegangen
was ist das
es ist einfach kunstvoll kunst ich weiß
gar nicht wie ich soll ich diese becken
heraus für mich so dass jeder möchte ich
gerne woanders also weil ich finde es
wahnsinnig interessant was sie gerade
sagen dass man die entwicklung nicht in
wiso erwartet man per se entwicklung
glauben sie also ich stelle mir vor dass
muss doch für die beiden so wahnsinnig
langweilig sein
für 50 aden immer nur das gleiche in
variation zu wiederholen oder möchten
sie sich mit leuten unterhalten die sich
seit fünf dekaden nicht weiterentwickelt
haben haye würde ich aber nicht sagen
dass sich nicht weiterentwickelt haben
und dann gibt es drei fahrer war
offenbar schon gesagt haben der umlauf
haben sie schon weiterentwicklung es
gibt noch etwas was mich dann
interessiert da gibt es ein anteil von
von sturheit von ich mach das ich ziehe
das durch ich bin kompromisslos auch
wenn die leute finden dass ich bin
bewegt sich nicht weiter das ist doch
das ist schwul das ist politisch
unkorrekt das ist unter fühlten uns
sieht's auch für den dreck sieht das
also da gibt es eine position das haben
sich auch eine provokation dass man
einfach sagt ok stuhl oder obsessiv ich
sie das jetzt einfach weiter pops euch
gefällt oder nicht
[Musik]
wie finde ich persönlich jetzt am
langweiligsten ehrlich gesagt ja wir
sind so das sind alles zeitungs
raushängen
genau wie man in england immer vor den
kirchen auf den plakaten mit dem das ist
im haus beginnen werden wird es nicht
das ist diesem moment mit den boni an
stars da sind die im rahmen 3000 das
haben das haben wir auch ausführlich
gewöhnen das ist nicht die pässe doppeln
lassen und mikroskop gemacht und dann
fotografiert ja dass hier sieht aus wie
ein auto und mit der spiegelung und der
symmetrie die dadurch entsteht dadurch
hat es sofort einen ganz stark
kompositionen die auch an sohn von
altmeister die sgm er hat ja und das ist
natürlich also eben solche politiker
werden findet sie aber wirklich dass in
diesem werk weiß ich auch nicht genau
die also mache ich das schreibe das
psychedelisch ich habe bei dieser ja so
eine psychedelische dunkle seite rein
kommt aber das sind doch nicht gilbert &
george town oder damals sind sie da oben
da schon oder aber aber daher das sind
dann auch die anderen jungs und dann
haben sie das ausgeschnitten und hinten
sind diese lachgas beendet dieses 76 zum
letzten mal ins kino und 95 männer
ausstellung anschauen geht mich nichts
mehr anfangen weil sie dann songs
eigentlich jeder sprache was machen sie
eigentlich im ganzen tag arbeiten und
sie stehen am morgen auf gehen raus sie
haben auch das einzige was wir haben ist
tee und so blieb es auch bis cochem
morgen sind die befürchtet mittag
darunter arten tag immer die gleichen
kanal in immerhin gleich und das gesamte
werk ist ja auch im londoner east end
quasi lokalisiert es ist ja nicht der
erste der die gesamte welt abbildet
eigentlich genau das was londoner east
end steht für die welt
auch als er geld wird man mehr zu
erkennen dort über das stimmt schon
das ist noch das 89 das ist noch von
hand gemacht
ich finde interessant in der
gesellschaft in der wir leben dass wir
einerseits dieses modell haben einer
künstlerischen existenz als massen
entwurf und andererseits für weiteres
mainstream oder sind das sieht nicht was
sie zudem an respekt sagen ob sie das
auch so sehen ich habe das gefühl dass
die die tatsächlichen künstler die
künstler im engeren sinne
andererseits einer viel größeren
moralische kontrolle unterworfen sind
als vor 30 40 jahren also die der
umstand dass man plötzlich wieder
anfängt über ein gemälde zu diskutieren
ob man die abhängen soll oder dass man
schauspieler nachträglich aus filmen
herausschneidet weil sie sich in ihrem
privatleben nicht akzeptabel genommen
haben
das sind wie zwei schalen einer waage
ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen
deswegen finde ich auch interessant
tausendmal jetzt zu zeigen 40 50 jahre
später das gewisse sachen die aus
vielleicht damals obszön galten dann
vielleicht der anfang der nullerjahre
aus völlig okay garten kann gut sein
dass in 245 jahren dass wir als obszön
gilt als wirkliche provokation nicht und
dass das ist eigentlich das interessante
an diesem berg dass sich daran die zeit
immer wieder
[Musik]
reibt und zerbricht
da
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich nehme an das wäre die wunsch frisur
von boris jones wenn wir das bild hier
angucken
es ist anders als die anderen und ich
für mich ist das ein schöner anlass über
gilbert & george als denn dies zu
sprechen
es wundert mich das wenig leute diese
ort für mich offensichtliche denn die
parallele ziehen
ich finde sie sind eigentlich
prototypische denn dies als figuren die
sich selbst inszenieren und vor allen
dingen für mich ist für den dandy wesens
mäßig dass er dazwischen steht also zu
keiner kategorie zugehörig ist immer ein
außenseiter ist aber trotzdem seine
subversion betreibt eigentlich aus einer
erscheinung die sehr kultiviert und auch
passend ist also die beiden herren sind
ja und das sehen wir auf diesem bild
vielleicht deutlicher als auf dem wo sie
gar nichts anhaben immer sehr ordentlich
angezogen im maßanzug ja das meine ich
damit und und sie legen ja auch wert
darauf sich als konservativ zu
bezeichnen
genau und das natürlich auch so ein teil
glaube ich eine wirkliche affirmationen
auch eine provokation nicht die sind die
kommen aus nicht mal aus mittel cross
das sagen wir selbst kommen eben aus
handwerkes familien aus dem südtirol im
falle von gilt sie sind nicht ab und
lasse sind auch nicht mit klasse und das
gehört natürlich dazu diese strategie
dass man eigentlich sozusagen die codes
der anderen sich mal an eignet oder
cloud und sich inszeniert nicht
inszenieren steht ja am anfang ist
arbeit die ob sie sind im militär schule
gegangen
in london schule war fertig und dann was
machen wir jetzt die meisten im
mittelkreis hintergrund hatten geld von
der familie muss nicht arbeiten
die hatten kein geld sagen sie und dann
haben sie diese living scouts
es waren wie ich ein bruch mit ganz viel
mich dass plötzlich ein mensch sich aus
skulptur inszeniert ist ja schon die
künstlichkeit der mensch aus künstliches
ding in den raum gestellt ist auch sehr
billig nicht weil du hast alles dabei
was die farbe noch bildrahmen und so
sind sie in die welt rausgezogen sind
aufgetreten und haben sich auch zum teil
in ausstellungen dann reingeschmuggelt
und das dass das ist das spiel auch dass
sie spielen das auch so sehen system sie
sagen wir wollen außenseiter bleiben
ich finde ganz interessant dass dieses
außenseitertum von den beiden ja auch in
die andere richtung praktiziert wird
also es gibt hier diese kommentare von
ihnen wo sie sagen in der kunstwelt muss
man links sein politisch links sein
können und das sind wir nicht denn
dieses dieser dieser wie sie sagen druck
links zu sein führt so genau der
gleichen konformität einfach mit anderen
vorzeichen es gibt auch diese äußerung
wo sie sagen wir haben überhaupt kein
interesse an sozialismus in der
sozialismus will dass alle gleich sind
und wir wollen anders sein wir wollen
genau das ist am besten die
schwierigkeit dass die für die befreiung
der sexualität sind gegen die religion
sind klassische linke themen nicht und
dann aber gleichzeitig viel dreck sitz
in gewissen nationalismus auch pflegen
englischen nation es nicht einen dritten
aber in englischen nationalismus das
glaube ich ist etwas was bis heute auch
tolles nachfristen ist dass man kommt in
dieser ausstellung ein und man ist eine
welt voller widersprüche
das ist und die muss man auch aushalten
können
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und dann frage ich mich immer bei
solchen sowas werken war was bleibt dann
wirklich also was wenn ich wieder
rausgehen hatte mich dass jetzt das hat
man ja auch sehr schnell erfasst haben
sich die zeit nehmen all diese parolen
zu lesen aber gar nicht aber wenn man
dann wieder rausgeht was hat man dann
irgendwie eine innere
verrückt oder veränderung erfahren oder
ist man irgendwie ein ganz kleines
bisschen ein anderer ich finde ja immer
dass es aber auch total altmodisch dass
man nach kontakt mit einem kunstwerk was
sich so nennen kann ein ganz kleines
bisschen ein anderer mensch ist als
vorher
ja und das ist genau habe das natürlich
also was wenn andere mäßig ein ding was
mich erstaunt dass ich es dass es mich
so eine wahnsinnig gute laune macht wie
oft komme ich aus einer ausstellung
beschwingt das finde ich auch ein
legitimes gehirn ich muss ich ihm mit
existenziellen überhaupt nicht der harz
irgendwas und dann hat es diese momente
dieser gruppe sind und ich mache das
gibt eine großzügigkeit nicht es gibt
eine ausführlichkeit nicht zwei künstler
in dem fall eigentlich immer
kontrollieren wollen uns ein bisschen
eng ich muss immer es muss immer wichtig
sein oder erfolgreichen oder die
abgeltungen ich bin sehr froh dass das
machen wir ja das für mich berührt das
den aspekt der unterhaltsamkeit ja und
unterhaltsamkeit ist so ein zu unrecht
diskreditiert das wort sagen nun auch in
bezug auf die literatur gehalt samt
heißt ja nicht dass man sich damit auf
die schenkel klopfen sondern einfach nur
das gegentor lang weil ja und ich finde
langweiligkeit am jeder form sei es
jetzt betulich oder klischeehaft oder
konventionell oder belehrend ist immer
der tod der kunst und deswegen bin ich
sehr froh dass ich diesen aspekt
ansprechen dass man einfach auch
unterhalten wird dass man in eine andere
stimmung kommt oder angeregt wird er
nicht langweilen das ist tatsächlich ein
auf 90 prozent steigen wie ich mir
anschaue bin ich gelangweilt und dann
wenn ich sowas finde ich vielleicht auch
nicht alles okay und gut aber ich
irgendwie ja tolle momente und das ist
für mich so leute denkt das ist einfach
nein das ist wahnsinnig schwierig tolle
momente des spiels
das muss man hinkriegen und das habe ich
auch immer ich hab so momente wo ich
einfach herrlich
was für ein schönes schlusswort auf
wiedersehen herr baumann jetzt nach
hause
[Gelächter]
ich habe mich gefragt ich glaube wir
haben tatsächlich alles gesagt was man
sagen kann oder
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur ist
reese los